I knew you were gonna say
that I knew you were gonna say that his
mom quit being his mom what does that
mean hey that doesn't mean that he just
Stomps mud through the
house what that means
is you take him out for breakfast and
you say hey we're eight years in I want
this to be my ride or die you are my
ride or
die and he is I know when you bring mud
in the house like when that when the
house is unclean I feel
unsafe I feel like I'm failing you I
feel like I'm failing a marriage I feel
like I got one job and I'm not doing it
right it honors me when that's different
than I told you right or even if you
didn't say don't say the words I told
you he can feel that tone all over your
body language when you go pick up his
shoes and throw them out on the front
porch